what makes a great crime drama when I
first started writing crime dramas I
asked myself the same question what
makes a great quiet drama and I couldn't
find a lot of resources so I started
watching binging watching watching
watching to find out yeah what does make
what makes for a good crime drama what
are the ingredients because I'm very
like I love to cook I love to bake so I
think in terms of ingredients so I came
up with this formula this recipe I think
basically I'll give you the ingredients
how we put them together I think is what
really makes you know a souffle better
than a another souffle but uh I think
first of all you start with this thing
called Mom what I call Mom and Pop so
like the foundation of every good family
is a mother and a father uh mom and pop
points of proof are what law enforcement
start with when they're investigating a
case and points of proof are Mom means
opportunity and motive so really
thinking through those three things
whenever I start a new to write a new or
develop a new crime drama I kind of
pretend like I'm making the case file
for my story and my crime and I start
with the way a detective would
um so what were the means opportunity
and motive of my criminal and I do a
pretty deep dive into that I'm not
talking just like one word like I really
go deep into what was the crime and why
was it especially why was it committed
um and then of course you have things
like you have to have crimes you have to
know the crimes there's usually more
than one crime that happens so like what
is your series of crimes how does that
build
um
there's
always then there's like obstacles and
these are really just story elements as
well but there have to be specific
obstacles at certain points along the
way that relate to how the criminal and
the
protagonists you know kind of do the cat
and mouse game I think too there are
I I believe and I think this is probably
the most important ingredient I believe
that the source or the foundation of
every great Crime Story is rooted in
love
and it could be a familial love like a
parent child or or two brothers
um it could be romantic love it could be
just an Agape like a friendship platonic
kind of love it could even be maybe a
self-love a person who's trying to
um forgive themselves for something or
come more into themself become more a
better person or the best version of
themselves but there's always I think
when you look at every great Crime Story
it's always rooted in love
look at Breaking Bad
it starts because Walter White wants to
take care of his family it's familial
love that's the entire basis of ever of
whatever he the whole thing why he does
what he does prisoners I don't know if
you ever saw prisoners it's a film by
Alcon entertainment Hugh Jackman and
Jake Gyllenhaal that is also familial
love everything that Hugh Jackman does
to try to solve this crime
is completely based in love for his
daughter
um anyway monk the TV show monk he comes
back to the force because he wants to
avenge his wife's death his death wife
was murdered and he wants to figure out
how wants to solve that case because of
his love for her so I think once you
nail that once you figure that out with
your protagonist
that to me is sort of the basis of a
really great crime story and then you
add all the other stuff you know your
case File your obstacles your crown your
crimes your motive means opportunity I
think you need to Pepper in some of the
story their story tropes for Crime genre
that you just sort of have to put in
there you know like maybe something
blows up a bad guy who's turns good or a
good guy turns bad you know there's
there's always at the end of act two
always uh you need to put your Heroes
life in danger you know the protagonist
who's trying to catch this criminal
almost dies right that whiff of death
moment and I think you need a little bit
of gallows humor I think that's kind of
like a little salt and pepper that you
need to put into it and then of course
character
um
I think that
all these great crime stories or like
when you look at any of the Hitchcock
stories they have amazing protagonists
and even the ones of modern
um the the protagonists are really
Dexter Walter White they're all very
um very very layered characters and so I
go through like a whole exercise to help
myself
really layer who is this not just a
detective or a an investigator it's like
there's got to be a lot more
to this character then they just want to
solve crimes like why are they solving
why are they doing this you know what is
why did they pick this thing to do
versus another thing to do so character
of course is
is
key
what kinds of characters do we most
often see in crime dramas any kinds of
characters
any any kinds of characters are in crime
dramas and that's because they think you
have
um
but when I teach on this I teach on 11
crime story types and I kind of go
through again when I was binge watching
years ago all these crime stories I
started to notice oh they all kind of
fall into like certain story types like
there's the traditional cop there's the
forensic specialist there's the profiler
um there's the Caper you know there's
all these 11 and so what I realized in
doing that is like literally anybody can
be an investigator you have a whole like
amateur amateur detective amateur sleuth
category so it could be a plumber it
could be a librarian you know um girl
with a dragon tattoo she's not a
professional law enforcement she's a
computer hacker uh Murder She Wrote
right just a writer just you know in a
small town so really the protagonists
can be anybody Walter White was a high
school teacher right
um
so I think that's what's so great and
then like if you get into like
Supernatural crime stories uh like
Supernatural I think they were brothers
if I remember right I haven't seen it
for a while but they can be any better
you have like the X-Files they it's
really kind of uh stranger things it's a
bunch of kids but they are solving a
crime they are solving a supernatural
crime that's going on in their
communities so really can be anybody
which is why I think this genre is so
widely appealing like is really
something for everybody
what's usually at stake
ah yeah was it always at stake
you know how you know again as writers
were like okay what does the character
want what does the character need and
it's like these two story lines always
flowing together the external goal and
then the internal goal so the external
goal is 99.9 of the time to catch the
killer to solve the case that's what the
protagonist wants they want to you know
restore the world of Justice redeem that
world
order the chaos right
the internal Drive is always the same
it's always the same overall goal it's
just different depending on who that
character is but it's and this is why I
think
that
um these grab people so much well any
great story will grab people the
internal goal for any protagonist or the
internal need I should say is if they
don't get that thing if they don't solve
that case or get that thing that they're
after
um because of whatever is going on
inside they will lose their soul
they will absolutely lose their soul
it's always like to say um
there are worse things than death death
is not the worst thing that can happen
to us
losing our soul is the worst thing that
can happen to us and I think that's why
when you find these really great stories
whether they're end up being you know
heroic stories or more tragic stories
again back to Breaking Bad
um the thing that Walter White's going
to lose if he doesn't provide for his
family is his soul he's he will have
lost a lot of other things but at the
core of himself he would have
it's like he would have failed
completely completely lose his soul if
he doesn't
you know step up and do this
so that's what I think is
always at stake so there has to be a
core of obsession
in in the character that's trying to
solve the crime wherever that is whether
it's like an actual detective or a
citizen journalist or somebody there's
like this they just like their whole
life will fall apart if they don't yeah
interest yeah I think so
um okay let's look at sharper I always
want to say sharper objects
um
so in sharp objects so let's look at and
I forget that I'm so bad for the names
but Amy Adams like her character you
know she's coming back to this small
town
to really unravel this horrific event
that happened and she's also struggling
right herself she's basically an
alcoholic if I remember bring that
correctly and so she knows I think we
see in her that she knows if she can't
get out of this cycle of alcoholism
she's going to lose herself she's going
to lose her soul the only way out of
that is she's got to uncover all this
stuff that's been going on back home
that she tried to run away from so if
she never ever ever in her entire life
solves that she'll never become whole
she'll lose her soul
right and it's a great opening too
because
um it hints at some of the stuff that
she went through and then she presents
to her editor or I forget if how the how
it goes down whether he presents to her
or she presents to him and she goes back
and it's so wonderful it's it is on so
many levels and he's that Mentor that
constantly challenging her right because
he knows she's gonna lose
she doesn't press
and she does be it does become an
obsession for her because there's a
certain point at which she's kind of a
sort of a reluctant hero at points or
you see her wanting to pull back but
then there's a point where she goes full
in because and it does become more of an
obsession because she
does realize if she does for many I mean
there's the external like I've got to do
this for everyone around me too and save
them but if I don't do it I'm I'm gonna
be lost forever my my whole being is
lost so it does become such an obsession
sure and it also too it has a lot of
baggage for her to go back because from
remembering correctly she grew up in in
room Gap and so she kind of has you know
bitter feelings but also some memories
that were bad and some that were you
know it's it was our whole being that
was back there exactly and she has to go
back and face that and then redeem it or
she has to redeem it somehow